Mr Foreign Minister, Germany has assumed a
seat for two years on the United Nations Security
Council.
What are your plans?
First of all, we will take an active role
in managing the crisises and conflicts being
handled by the Security Council.
They include Syria, Yemen, Ukraine and now
Venezuela.
This is an important task and it's clear that
people have expectations of us: we're expected
to take responsibility and that's something
we want to do.
Apart from that, there are important topics
of our own that we would like to put to the
Security Council.
Climate and security is one of those issues
that is not getting enough attention -- and
the connection between climate change and
security issues is becoming increasingly important.
We want to put the role and experience of
women in war higher on the agenda.
There is much to do.
The United Nations is doing a lot already,
but we have to do even more because women
are often the first to suffer in conflict
and women often have special skills that can
help settle these conflicts later on.
Humanitarian law and humanitarian aid is also
important to us.
Many die trying to help others.
We have to change that and change the legal
framework.
The biggest issue, though, is disarmament.
This is also an issue that has to be discussed
with the global community.
As you can see, we have many initiatives and
talking points that are important to us, and
which the Security Council will have to consider.
The United States and Russia are at odds over
many issues at the moment.
It is said that the Security Council's ability
to act is therefore limited.
You've just met the foreign ministers of both
countries in Moscow and Washington.
What role can Germany play?
Can it mediate?
We don't want to pretend to be more important
than we really are.
But I have spoken with Foreign Minister Lawrow
in Moscow as well as with Secretary of State
Pompeo in Washington.
There are issues that are not only of interest
to the US and Russia, such as the future of
the INF treaty.
Wherever we can help to create an understanding
between them, we are happy to do so.
But it's not just about Russia and the US:
China also has a part to play in the issue
of disarmament.
And we will be very active over the coming
weeks and months in this regard.
Radical change is happening in Venezuela at
the moment.
Germany and the European Union haven't recognised
the new, self-proclaimed acting president.
Can Germany afford to be neutral?
We are not neutral.
We are on Juan Guaidó's side because it is
difficult for us to recognise the legitimacy
of Maduro's re-election.
It's obvious that there were so many irregularities
in the election that we can only speak to
a limited degree of a democratic election.
That's why we are calling for fresh elections,
for the National Assembly to assume responsibility
and for constitutional law to be restored
in Venezuela.
We have made that known together with our
European partners.
That's going to be our policy over the coming
days and I expect that this will be made very
clear.
We are NOT neutral.
We support what Guaidó is doing.
Thank you for the interview.
You're welcome.